just a moment first i want to introduce
you to our very special guest this hour
the actress the author the queen of
hollywood showbreez royalty no less dame
joan collins well thank you very much
for joining us well i mean what did you
make fedor it was
totally awe-inspiring i have to say i've
been watching it on this channel since
10 30 this morning
glued to the television set and when all
of the planes flew over it was i wanted
to cry it reminded me a lot of being in
the war actually
yeah you know it looked also as if the
queen felt the same because really did
you yeah she she made some gesture about
the sound of the planes that was it the
sound but the sound that we used to hear
was there was a potential bomb this was
just it was awe-inspiring and it was so
they flew so low it was extraordinary
didn't then
i mean we could hit i had to put my
hands in my ears it was so loud but the
whole thing with the queen because the
last time
i saw a picture of the queen it was at
prince philip's memorial at his funeral
and she was sitting alone and looking so
sad and everybody's been so worried
about her but she has been so robust she
has been so
on the ball and so great looking i mean
her outfits her smile she's wearing
lovely
makeup and everything it was great i
mean that's a very good point you made
because she was so alone wasn't she
totally
totally now
i mean the crowds
the crowds are extraordinary and they're
also well behaved they were yes
i have to mainly yeah i saw a couple of
uh yeah but we don't talk about those
but just the the you know the sort of
streaming down the mall the pictures all
those people the multitudes yes it was
so good i hope it's going to be like
this on sunday because i'm in the royal
procession
and i've heard there's an 80 chance of
rain this is not such good news for me
well i'm sure it'll be fine i mean it's
warm now though isn't it
what did you
love most about the day
i think what i love most about
everything really but i think i love
seeing
um
prince william and
catherine's three children sitting
or
sort of really stunned well the little
one louie he i don't think he'd ever
been out before in one of these events
and how he
was reacting on the balcony i thought
that was so adorable and so really good
down to earth this is what i always felt
about the queen and i've met her quite a
few times
she's so down to us you think you can
have a jolly old chat with her over the
garden wall if she lived next door to
you and and we had and i'd been i met
her first and i think the
1968 at the premiere and i've met her
consistently since and she's always been
so charming and so real well you're with
us for the hour i want to talk to you
about uh that in a little bit uh but i
but just on louie i mean he young louis
he was in the carriage he was sort of
learned getting the royal way wasn't he
going and all that he was doing that
little thing like that yeah the uh
prince george was sophisticated he'd
done it before
and prince charlotte well she's our
future it girl isn't she i mean she is
just so
cute and adorable and lovely little
dress and just you know these pictures
we're seeing now the pageantry and the
you know only in english
oh no no no no that's why we have so
many tourists here that's why you can't
get a taxi
there's so many people here now you had
a limousine and then you must have had a
limo
taxes yeah i'm an honorary taxi driver
actually because i take so many and i
think that there's a certain
i hate to say the word jealousy but i
think there's a certain envy with
certain other countries that we have
these amazing events amazing we seem to
have one every two or three years it's a
royal wedding or it's an event like this
i remember the the last one i was in
america they they look so stunning those
two ladies yeah absolutely they're
they're they're the uh children you
mentioned the two duchesses they look
amazing and also the horses were so well
behaved weren't they
the horses well there was one that
looked a bit frisky
right at the beginning did you see that
yes i was um
doing i was talking to somebody on the
phone and i said oh my god i think one
of the horses is about to bolt
but it does
it all went well didn't it i think the
queen should be thrilled and i think do
you think she enjoyed it i mean it was a
joyous how could you not enjoy it yeah i
mean with the perfect weather
and everything went according to plan
and the family was there all of the
people that she loves and they're you
know i feel very that strongly about
family i think it's you know the glue
that holds us together and i i i'm sure
she loved it and i'm sure she was so so
happy to be here and now she's got to
light the beacon hasn't she she has yeah
she's got to do that
she's got she's going to make a few
appearances i think because at one stage
it looked as though that you know there
wouldn't be so many appearances i know
so many people were very very
pessimistic about her all right well
look so much to talk about uh stay with
us maybe get in the shade or something
we're gonna have a look at some of the
uh highlights of the days
celebrations